ICE.
CARTER VERHAEGHE HE WILL TRY
TURNS EMMETT PICKS ITTHE BIG CH
THEIR AFTER THE ICING CALL. ICE
LONG, FORWARD PASSES.
THIS PLAY STARTED BACK WHENR OW
NET THE RIGHT DECI
.
>>Steve: GOOD START TO THIS
GAME F 1-0
RANGERS, RANDY.
>>Randy: L LONLY PLAYED
FIVE GAMES THAT BACK HAND
DEFLECTEDONCE IN AWHILE.
LOOKS AND ALL
ABLE TO THE SHOT APPLY IN THE J
STOCKING
THE PANTHER ROOKIE KNOWS EACH
OTHER WELL.
GETS TAKEN
-
>>Randy: HUGE GOAL FOR THE
FLORIDATHERE IN
FRONT BOTHERING THE GOALTENDER
SHESTERKIN.  POINT
NO TAKES THE  BUT MAYOR
NAGIN HAS THE RANGER GOAL OR
SHOWING TALENT HE POSSESSES IS
THE RANGERS NUMBER 1PASS, SHOT
BOBROVSKY ON FOX.
TAKE
>>Randy: PANTHERS FINAL REWARD
FOR THEIR HARD WORK IN THE
Randy: HAD HIMSELF A LITTLE
SMILE THERE.
>>Steve: ON, SAVE BY BENNETT, S
WHAT A THIRD-PERIOD
.
>>Randy:y:IS THE BLOCK, SACRIFI
THE BODY,
>>Steve: FINALLY ABLE TO CHANGEA